[Music]
hi everyone it's really nice to be here
thanks for the invitation
I want to tell you about uh quibble it's
a new open source package for inherently
interactive data exploration it's a tool
that was developed by a team including
myself and these two amazing amazing
people that you see here mahokian and
kleinberger two amazing python wizard
maukaun is actually here raise your hand
yes yeah okay
so I want to be honest I actually have
like two three slides that are more like
an introduction background philosophy
and blah blah blah that I know that some
people just say I'm gonna lose you you
just want to see code so I think with
the inspiration of Raymond this morning
I'm actually going to show you a quick
fun demo of the pitago mcum
okay
and then we'll go back to the original
presentation okay
so here is a very simple code you cannot
just look at it the tools uh the
triangle let's Let Me Line it does a
Time girl together with the Pythagorean
squares around it okay and like many
chords it has parameters in this case
the legs A and B of the triangle
if we want to change those parameters I
would have to go to the code here and
change them and run again
and it would be nice if I can do that
interactively ideally maybe if I can
drag that point or this point it
represents the A and B that would be fun
but to do something like that in Python
would be very difficult right
okay this is where quiver comes in and
in quid layer
all you need is
okay so it is pretty much just one
command you have to know I equip you
take your normal code
okay normal code and you just I quit the
input quib equip you inputs
right click your input the rest is a
totally normal gorgeous profile plot
text text okay
so let's let's run it and see what
happened
okay so it creates exactly the same
thing but now if you look at it
whoop
nice huh
and that's fine but actually equivalent
is smarter than that it actually
understands the entire arithmetic and
geometrical relationships here so you
can also go and drag that point
nice huh oh that point
okay or even that point
[Music]
okay you got it
okay so that is uh thank you very much
for uh the inspiration of using the
Pythagorean theorem and we'll go back to
the talk
um so how did we get you I want to tell
you a bit about uh my own journey I
started my career in physics and
computer science in the third period
program is then shifted to biology works
on microbial Evolution then I I joined
Harvard Medical School where I became a
professor of systems biology well my lab
really developed genomics approaches to
understand and predict how bacteria
become resistant to antibiotics then I
moved to the technion where my group
developed experimental tools and a big
data machine learning tools in the area
of digital Health to and specifically in
infectious disease
and throughout this journey I've been
involved in multiple very different data
science data analysis projects involving
very very different type of data sets
from
numerical simulation to to Imaging to
genomics to electronic health cycodes
and others
and I noticed over time that despite a
very different uh type of these data
sets and the very different nature even
of the project they often share very
similar challenges that they want to
explain here
so here is your typical data analysis
pipeline we start
um on the left we start on the left with
a lot of data we go through a series of
transformational steps and then we
present something that we are interested
in for example philosophies could be a
lot of health records of patients and
maybe what we want to see is what is the
efficacy of different drugs
and we look at the result and we might
want to conclude hey drag a here is more
effective than that boc that would be an
important result but of course we have
to be careful why because this pipeline
are notoriously highly parametized
multiple different parameters we had to
choose as we went to what was the age
limit for the population what was it
where the exclusion criteria what was
the averaging window what was the
beginning size what background I
subtracted from images many many
parameters right and these parameters
ultimately affect my result
and I won't tell you in my experience a
big part and I think also the fun part
of being of the data science data
scientist job is to understand those
relationship relationships between
parameters and results
to uh wisely and informally tune and
choose your parameters and also to make
changes in these parameters and see how
they affect Downstream results
and that really brings about four key
challenges that I listed here first
traceability I'm looking at the result
how do I even know what it depends on
second reproducibility I have a
parameter I want to change it how do I
do it in a transparent uh
well-documented reproducible way
third
efficiency I've made a change what and I
want to see how it affect my result what
do I do I run the whole thing or do I
have a way to only run Downstream steps
and maybe even have a way to only run
specific slices specific item within
those Downstream steps okay and finally
interactivity ideally I want to do that
like I've shown you with the time girl
uh in an inter interactive fan a fun way
and I want to interactive is fine but
it's also much more effective when you
get to data okay so quibble is really a
tool set that is meant to tackle all
four of these key challenges
traceability reproducibility
efficiency and transparency and very
important with Scribbler it does that
with well requiring the user to learn
very very little to a good extent to get
started all you need is iqb all you need
is to equip your inputs and use standard
normal python code just comes to life
okay I do want to mention as a packages
related to the packages that addresses a
similar related issues mainly focusing
on the issue of graphic presentation in
interactive Graphics maybe some at least
on the others issues and for
interactivity they offer different
solutions to complementary solutions to
equiblio they're very interesting very
powerful I do encourage you to check
them out
okay
so for for the rest of the talk what
they want to do is uh show you a few
examples in quibble the demonstrate is
for capacities and we're going to
emphasize mainly interactivity and hint
on the other three
okay
so interactivity how do we normally
think about interactive code
so here's the most if you want classic
canonical code for interactivity I
downloaded it from the official uh
documentations of matplotlib okay and
what it does it creates uh an image here
it it plot an image here and allow you
in plot a histogram of intensities and
allow you to play with a widget
with those Lim with a limit of uh the
bot top and bottom limits of intensity
and thereby enhance your image
now what they want to do is spend uh
maybe a couple of minutes with you to
wait what the code is doing and then
we'll think about how it might be
implemented in in a different approach
okay so what happened here we start with
defining the limits for the color the
black and white limits okay then we plot
the image already with the correct
limits in place okay then we plot the
histogram then we plot this left line
the right line that represents our
choices and then we have the slider
so at that point we've effectively done
Computing everything and plotting
everything okay what comes afterwards is
what we call the Callback function if
that's a function that is being called
whenever someone play with a widget and
let's see what it does okay it starts
with resetting uh the limits of the
image that we've already defined above
okay then it resets the position of the
left bar here that we've already set
above then it will set the position of
the writer which we've already set about
okay then we need to redraw everything
and finally we need to connect our
slider to this Copic function
okay
so when I'm looking at that I would say
three things bothers me see
it's the first one is why do I need to
test the computer everything two times
I've just told it how to plot everything
in the right place given the original
value of the parameters why do I need to
specify how to repload everything when
parameter change that's fine
so this equation of tedious programming
of callback functions
the second which is not as important we
somehow tend to delegate interactivity
to outside the widgets what I really
wanted to do is go and drag these lines
here that's what I want to do okay but
to do that I create a widget that drag
the change the line for me so the
graphic itself is reactive it's not
itself interactive okay and the third
part is okay I'm making all of these
changes where do they get saved how do I
go back how do I actually nail down
something is it
okay so I want to show you how that
would look in quiblia
okay
so here is the same code I've shown you
and let me run it
okay and it creates uh the same widgets
that I've shown you and we can play with
it this way
okay
um so that's a classic now let's see how
that would look in queer so equivalent
what we said we go to our input we take
a normal code is everything standard we
just go to our input and I equip them
input quid and clip
okay and then I don't need the Callback
function at all so just delete delete
delete delete delete delete delete
delete delete delete delete delete
delete delete delete delete delete
delete
delete
okay also not need to connect anything
so delete
I would argue I also don't need this
part because that was just used to
transfer information into my callbacks I
don't need this part
okay much nicer code let's run it
okay
so times exactly the same
A2 operates exactly the same but we we
didn't need to program any any callbacks
but everything just works okay but now
look at that we can also drag this one
oops right
it's all connected I never needed to
specify any callbacks and I think it's
just immediately Interactive
okay I would argue that at that point if
the graphic itself is interactive why do
you even need the widget so I have to
even just go and delete all of that how
about this
so I would argue this is this is really
my code here
okay so instead of a 20 line code it's a
five line code instead of a 20 line
complicated code it's a five line data
scientist code just
calculate and plot that's what I want
right okay let's see what happened
okay everything just works and we have a
widget here
Okay so
okay
now I want to do something
if you have
if you are saving time or writing
complicated codes and instead
you have time I
spending that time actually looking at
your data and develop some intimate
relationship with your data then you may
actually discover something new that you
didn't see before for example you may
ask yourself hey what is that little
hump here and if you have the
interactive tools you may immediately
zoom in it and see what it is
okay
okay uh it's actually you get for free
as a very fine capacities
for example
so this doesn't work on the screen
that's why I have to to keep it uh on
the bigger okay for example
you see how we have here in Andrew
button can undo
redo
okay that's fine if that's inherent in
again just come for free the other thing
is about uh
um transparency well so in making these
changes where do they actually get
registered when I move that what
how do I go back to let's say that was a
fun like a fun a good position and now
um where does that value get recorded so
if we go to our limits which was
um
so that that variable here right and I
look at it it would tell me hey what
happened we started with 10 to 40 but
then someone came and overreading those
values and specifically at position zero
it's a 146 that we have here and if I
drag that these numbers changes
okay so that in a way is a human
readable uh
documentation of everything we're doing
okay we can save that for example we can
save it to the network network we can
save it to external file little human
review but just text change change
change okay then if I come back
um later on I can load I can load it
depending on specific name specific
version so you can load here and come
back
okay
I think we've covered all of these parts
let's go back here
so I think what I've shown you is so far
is that quibbler really takes you normal
standard code and brings it to life
it pretty much only requires you to
equip your inputs and the rest of it
just happen automatically in some way
and in what way I want to explain now
which is
how does ah sorry I do have one more
slide so if this slide just just to say
you can now imagine how just easy it is
to write many different applications
many different domains of data science
Mass physics simulations all of these
interactive code application to see here
pretty much just a few lines of code
that Dimitri give you all the
interactivity
very cool for uh ml model hyper
parameter specification for Imaging and
for many other things
okay
okay so how does it work
quiver is based on a data flow Computing
Paradigm what does it mean it means we
have objects that are connected to
another and flow information between
them okay more specifically we Define
the quib that the entire thing is based
on one type of object one class is
equipped class and equip is an object
that represents a value together with a
functioning arguments needed to
calculate that value okay okay so let's
see what it means
I can create input quiz input query by
we can create them with the IQ command
detection and anything can be an input
for example here I enter an input query
of a list save equip that represent a
list if I ask you ask the quib what's
your value it tells me hey that's my
valuity list
okay
now the beauty is every time I apply
a function in operation get item slicing
what's not on equip
it doesn't get performed immediately
what I get is a new equip a function
equip whose function is to perform the
operation I just requested okay so for
example if I go B is a slice of a b who
are you instead I'm the slicing of a
that's my function to slice a what's
your value now it actually slice and
that's my value
C is a log of B see who are you I'm
logos B what's your value that's my
value so this part is lazy it's just
declarative okay the actual calculation
only happened when needed
okay and we can keep going maybe flip
maybe operations are also all
implemented okay so you can just use
normal syntax and you keep it in a way
what you keep doing is creating a
network a dxyclic graph of connected uh
connected quips
okay so you can immediately imagine if
something changed Upstream root it will
percolate to affect information
Downstream okay
is smarter than that in two very
important ways okay two very important
ways
first one it doesn't just say B depend
on a as a whole it actually knows which
specific elements within B depend on
which specific elements within a what
does that mean that means that if
something change Upstream so for example
if I go and say a of 6 equals 16 okay it
would calculate it down but only
affecting and only recalculating those
specific items that got affected
okay
this one and that would ultimately
result in the change here
so two things in terms of efficiency
only Parts down stream get calculated
that's why in only specific data item
specific elements within those parts
actually get calculated okay
second
is the feature that actually brings
about this magical interactivity
equivalent unlike normal data flow
realization can actually also flow
information backwards absolutely okay
what does it mean if I ask I want to
substitute to assign 14 at that position
so it would say but this is a function
how can I do that ah if I if I can
reverse that function that would mean I
need 4 here that means I need 4 here now
if that was a logs I need to do X okay
so that would be 16 here so I actually
need 16 there okay so that that's what
will happen
okay sorry
as a video okay okay so it inverse we
call it inverse assignment okay it it
can only work when the functions are
invertible but pretty much when you
actually present data a lot of what you
do is invertible function and it will
just work out of the box like that
okay
um so why is that important because when
that changed now anything else that may
depend on it will also change okay so if
I'm presenting a quib in two different
ways as a plot of X and the plot of
something else two different
graphical presentation of the same item
okay then the immediately become
connected
if I interact with that graphic it would
inverse propagate and change the
equivalent that that change would
percolate to both of these so that's
really what happened when we looked at
the Pythagorean right these different
points they represent different uh
functional different graphical
realization of those same parameters A
and B and equivalent knows how to
percolate it back all the time to the
underlying parameters all of these
changes
okay
so
we you looked at that and you might be
wondering how could it could this ever
happen and this only happened because
we've actually went and modified
when we start quibbler we go initially
equivalent that goes and modify all of
numpy function all of multiple Loop
function all of Ip widgets py widget
functions all operators get item and and
many other things in making them what we
call a quiby functions that can work on
creep and create new creeps okay
okay sorry should I put that one here
okay now what happened if you have
another function from another tool that
we've not implemented yet or you have
your own user function that's very easy
what you do you use we give you an up a
decorator which is quite a creepy
decorator and you decorate your
functions with that and then I want to
show you an example of that
okay
so here is um an OD or ordinary
differential equation solver okay so uh
and let me just run it okay
for uh it's a very classical ecological
case of UF access and they play on
rabbits and then there are too many
foxes the rabbits die and then they
don't have food so there are the the
foxes die and then the rabbit's life and
you get those waves that you see here
okay
now if I want to make that interactive
these are not interactive now because I
this is a classical code and I never
specified a callback functions they just
won't go okay but if I want to make it
interactive I just need to go and say
here that my initial condition that an
input I equip that these are initial
these are the interactions between the
foxes and the rabbit I like with that
okay but now I need to be a bit careful
because I'm actually putting this into a
function that is not numpy microclip ipy
Widgets or classical python so that's my
own function so I need to go and see
where it's defined and just add that
query here okay the function itself
doesn't know it just works normally it
works and a normal variable you can see
it actually calls a solver from side by
it's all fine you just put this thing
here okay let's run it again
okay right okay so now these are
immediately Interactive
okay you see
that's fun
but also it's really fun that you can
put your initial condition right here
when they belong and not in the slider
and move them like that
okay
okay
so going back
we talked about Creepy functions about
how many packages are already equipped
classical but how we can make any
function view on quiby and lastly I want
to talk about an actual application we
are running in the lab
here you see uh microscopy image of
bacteria that we've labeled with three
different colors red green and blue okay
and they're locked inside little micro
scale door plates of water surrounded by
oil okay and our task is to choose one
of them
crop it out and uh and
um
and and count what is the total area of
red green and blue batik bacteria that
they have there okay so here is a little
uh apps it does exactly that it allows
you to to move your Center to change the
circle it does a copying protocol being
here
then threshold the colors allow you to
change the thresholds of the colors
change the which color you're doing
within with the radio button and always
show you how much you have of the red
green and blue within that Circle
okay time
five-ish okay very good okay
we're not going to read the whole code
but what I want you to notice the entire
thing the dragging the circles this box
here the zooming in the thresholdings
the histogram moving that that line
everything interactive it's just those
30 line of code okay and what's
important is not only the shortcode it's
a code that is a data scientist called
it's just calculates plot calculate plot
calculate plot okay
we're not going to go into it but just
to give some sense we'll take this part
just the beginning part and I'll show
you how that is implemented
okay
so let's start here we are plotting just
an X Y point
and it's an IQ so that immediately is
interactive I can just go and oops nice
okay
now let's plot a circle and you'll
notice I nothing special I just use
cosine and sine to plot the circles in a
way any high schooler would do and that
is also immediately Interactive
okay let's add the text box
for the radius
Interactive
okay but let's do something more fun
I'll add the text box for the diameter
2L here
okay
so the diameter obviously depends on the
radius and when the radius change the
diameter change but you can also go here
and say 100
it just inverted that function the 2R to
give you 50 here
okay that's how the inversion actually
makes it all connected and fun okay now
let's load the image just load again
it's just normal
normal
command and we're just going to do uh
we're just going to slice our image with
a normal slicing syntax and plot it and
we immediately got an interactive GUI
see
look at that side
okay
last thing about that is undo redo okay
we can undo and we do have shown you
that okay
but
last thing about traceability okay let
me looking at something here this is a
simple example but you can imagine more
complicated and I want to know what it
depends on okay
so that was
um
this variable here uh where was it it's
a sub image okay so if I go and I say
give me the dependency graph of sub
image
it will go and say
it's essentially give me my code as a
graph
okay what did we have where the file uh
file name we read it with image red okay
then we sliced it based on the centers
and the intelligence and then we plotted
that slice and that's how we got here
Okay so now you can immediately say okay
what effect it is the radius and and the
center I can I can also look at them I
can like like I've shown in the
beginning you can ask okay what is the
radius the radius has been 60 but we
just said change it to 46 that's by by
dragging that right okay and again that
can be saved these are obviously very
kind of small example but when you have
large data sets for example let me show
you
for example maybe a more realistic
implementation is the one shown here
where you have you're copying many
things and you're saving all of these
centers and you have a human readable
record of what you've done and also any
change you do only the parts that need
to be recalculated is actually being
like recalculated so everything is very
effective okay
conclusion I've shown you a new package
uh queebler it's open source ready to
use we just launched it uh officially
yesterday so you're very welcome to be
the first one looking at it it offers a
solution for key issues in data data
analysis traceability reproducibility
efficiency and interactivity
and very importantly it requires you to
learn very very little to a good extent
all you have to do is equip your input
and your code comes to life okay
um I want to say I demonstrated mainly
applications it goes with to go with
imaging just because it's much more for
the presentation but it's a very general
tool it can go in many different things
and I really encourage you to try it out
I'm really curious to see what type of
application people can think about we
are really looking for engagement from
users and from developers writers of any
suggestions you might have uh any help I
think using the code would be great and
any suggestions for improvement and if
you're a developer and you want to join
and help that would be very very welcome
and I want to say to get this boosted
and get you uh on it we're actually
declaring right now hereby declaring
announcing the quibble Awards the
quibble award
so what is equivalent is a short lesson
40 line code it does something fun with
quibbler something interactive with
graphics and ideally show some domain of
application even just touch an idea if
you're up to it try it out and we have a
submission deadline next Thursday
with some significant award here that
are listed below right there okay all
the details are on this website and
everything need to be submitted to
quibbler at technion ACL we're gonna we
have an international award committee
and we are ready to to explore and
everything are going to be published at
the end in a website with all the
examples so that would be fun
q a
what did you need to add the file into
the qba
thanks very good very good because after
that I I did I am read okay and I wanted
the result of that to be equipped
okay I could have done it other way but
that's the easiest way it's the easiest
way to convince I'm read that I'm
actually I want a function I wanted an
output that is equipped because then I
want to slice it and I want it to be
slight the creepy way functionally right
if yeah I think generally if you're
unsure about which parameters just I
equipped in nothing's gonna happen just
yeah
yes
and several others if you think about
expanding the newer visualization Stacks
basically all of this
plotly is surely the next one on the
list but I think right now we just felt
we want to open it and start to get some
help because I mean each one of these is
some some effort and I think it requires
a community effort and that's why that's
why I'm here
[Music]
okay we can talk yeah
[Music]
it's sometimes even better than without
using uh equivalent in the sense of
memory and time why because suppose you
have a big a big pile of uh of images
and you and you apply uh we know the way
we actually approach a lot of data is
with the numpy vectorized syntax so that
allows you to take any function and
apply to each item in in in an array
okay if you use normal Vector wise it
will just apply a function to all the
elements okay but suppose that you have
a million of elements and the function
is costly it's not what you want to do
for people with declarative and that
means that you just declare my output is
applying that function medium time but
if I just want the output in position
seven you just want to apply it at
position seven if you just change
something Upstate in position eight
you're just going to invalidate the
cache at position a okay so it can
actually work on a lot on on large data
sets with
played uh mainly with respect to
um image analysis we played with quite a
big amount of images and it's really fun
and also if something is not presented
graphically
then unless you actually say get value
it doesn't even get calculated
I think yes
[Music]
sure sure it's all it's all um even the
one I've shown you is it's all it's VSC
click
uh graph but it's it's not linear it's a
it's it's a punching like the graphs
linear right it's not it's not always
easy to draw the graph when the
componential is more complex I guess
um
so so for example here
how do you know ah okay okay okay got
you got you okay okay so when I said it
you normal code come to life I was
cheating you cannot do if for example
and if you are doing a fall you have to
be uh carefully you can do a for Loop
you can even uh you can iterate over
quiz also but if you're doing that you
have to uh to think in advance whether
the size of the quib itself going to
change if it is then don't do it fall
then do a numpy vectorize think about
about how you actually take a function
apply to each element of your data if
you want to do a four you can do a four
but that would only work it would be
perfectly fine as long as thing don't
change in size if it does change in size
there's no problem but you the syntax of
a four is not the right one you want to
adapt the syntax of a numpy vectorized
which means here's my function applied
to all of these items right and that way
you can keep changing chaining
um complex operations that are not
implemented as as quids you have you
have your own big function they do
complicated stuff you the way you wrap
them as quips it's just a wrap here like
I'm showing you with uh with a logical
volteras and foxes and and uh and
rabbits it's in a similar way you can
also apply function to many elements of
another and it will only it would just
be a wrapper so you can still use all
the functions you've already deleted and
you can just use them as they are
please
q a done that's what it means yay thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]